Avec nous Didier Houssin,
président du comité d'urgence
COVID-19 de l'Organisation
mondiale de la santé, l'OMS.
Professeur Houssin, bonsoir!
- Bonsoir, monsieur!
- Alors, d'abord,
vous avez publié un livre.
Vous êtes à l'OMS.
Première question que les gens
se posent : est-ce que
cette pandémie va finir un jour
ou on va devoir cohabiter
avec le virus pendant
de nombreuses années?
DIDIER HOUSSIN, président,
comité d'urgence COVID-19, OMS
- Bien, en fait, aujourd'hui,
je crois que personne ne sait.
Personne ne sait. Les deux
scénarios sont possibles.
Il y a même peut-être d'autres
scénarios encore.
Mais il est possible
qu'effectivement on soit amenés
à cohabiter comme on cohabite
avec les virus de la grippe
chaque année tant bien que mal.
Et puis, on peut aussi assister
à une sorte de disparition
du virus, mais qui reparaîtra
tard sous une autre forme,
un nouveau coronavirus.
En fait, on ne sait pas.
- Parce que, au départ
de cette crise, on avait
beaucoup un vocabulaire
guerrier. On disait :
"Il faut abattre, il faut tuer,
il faut vaincre le virus."
Et on s'aperçoit peu à peu
qu'on est venu à la cohabitation
nécessaire.
- Oui, alors, il fallait
quand même, je crois, au début,
mobiliser beaucoup les énergies.
Et malgré tout, il y a
des actions conduites qui
ont une efficacité. Les mesures
dites non pharmacologiques,
le port du masque, la distance,
la ventilation des espaces
fermés, l'hygiène des mains
sont des mesures extrêmement
importantes pour réduire
le risque. Et puis, il y a
la vaccination. Et donc,
je pense qu'il ne faut
pas négliger, malgré tout,
les actions efficaces qui ont
été conduites et qui ont réclamé
une certaine mobilisation
au départ.
- Bon, parlant de mesures
efficaces, il y a
la vaccination. Je vous donne
deux chiffres, professeur
Houssin, pour la planète.
Première dose, couverture
vaccinale de première doses :
33 % à l'échelle mondiale.
Deuxième dose, c'est
encore plus bas : 25 %.
Je vous montre une carte.
C'est très inégal.
Au Canada, on est à 66 %.
En Europe, 45. Ça, c'est les
deux doses. États-Unis : 51.
Asie : 25. Afrique : à peine
3 %. Alors, il y a une iniquité.
On voit, dans certains pays,
comme le Canada comme en Europe,
les États-Unis, on discute déjà
de la troisième dose, alors que
la majorité de la planète n'a
même pas eu sa première dose.
Où vous en êtes dans l'analyse?
- Bien, vous mettez le doigt sur
l'une des difficultés majeures
actuelles à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés, quand je dis nous,
je me mets un peu à la place
du directeur général de l'OMS
et aussi de nombreux acteurs.
C'est-à-dire que, effectivement,
la vaccination est efficace.
Aujourd'hui, elle s'est bien
développée, même si elle n'a
pas encore atteint un niveau
suffisant dans, entre
guillemets, les pays riches.
Mais la difficulté, c'est
qu'effectivement, les pays
pauvres ont un accès aujourd'hui
limité à la vaccination.
Il n'est pas nul, mais il est
trop faible. Et vous avez
raison d'évoquer la...
Alors, certains la présentent
comme une alternative.
Peut-être que ce n'est pas une
alternative, mais effectivement,
il va falloir... va-t-il falloir
surprotéger en proposant
une troisième dose ou un rappel
à certaines personnes?
Ou vaudrait-il pas mieux essayer
d'accentuer l'initiative COVAX
pour donner accès en plus grand
nombre aux vaccins dans
des pays aujourd'hui démunis?
- Et vous répondez quoi
à cette question? Est-ce qu'on
devrait privilégier...
- Aujourd'hui, je réponds qu'il
vaut mieux essayer de développer
la vaccination dans les pays
démunis parce qu'il est
vraisemblable que, si on veut
tenter de maîtriser cette
pandémie, il faut quand même
essayer d'avoir une vue globale
et penser à la maîtriser à la
surface du globe en totalité.
- Je boucle la boucle.
On parlait de cohabiter avec...
avec la COVID. Combien de temps
encore on sera en alerte comme
ça, d'après vous?
- Bien, vous savez, le comité
d'urgence, que j'ai l'honneur
de présider, il se réunit à peu
près tous les trois mois,
et on lui pose uniquement...
la première question qu'on lui
pose c'est : "Est-ce que c'est
toujours une urgence de santé
publique de portée
internationale?"
Et je dois dire que jusqu'à
présent, la réponse a été
unanimement oui.
Et vous le comprenez bien.
On aura une nouvelle réunion
en octobre. Je pressens
qu'en octobre, l'affaire ne sera
pas terminée. Maintenant, aller
plus loin dans la prédiction,
vous savez... C'est Woody Allen
qui disait : "Les prévisions
sont toujours difficiles en
particulier à propos du futur."
Et cette pandémie est capable
de nous réserver quand même
des mauvaises surprises encore.
- OK, alors, jusqu'à la fin
de l'automne, en tout cas,
on est en urgence sanitaire.
- Oui, oui, c'est très
vraisemblable. Enfin, à moins
d'un miracle, je vois mal
comment, fin octobre,
on pourrait... le comité
pourrait dire au directeur
général : "Ça n'est plus une
urgence de santé publique de
portée internationale."
Ça m'étonnerait, hein!
- On croit mal aux miracles.
En tout cas, c'est plus
difficile. Didier Houssin,
professeur, président du comité
d'urgence COVID-19 de l'OMS,
merci de nous avoir parlé!
- Merci de votre invitatio